[Music]
no
no happy
birthday to
you this is a
present analyzing your DNA this will
sound crazy but I have a twin he was
kidnapped when he was a baby it's
you we're looking for this
house my brother welcome
home we have a deep spiritual connection
in this
family that's mommy she's so
beautiful do you want to meet
her what's up
[Music]
this Vision that haunts you it just
means you're part of this
family and these people are weird we
found a genetic anomaly this is
disconcerting she wants to take my voice
away from
me wake up do you see a vision from the
past this gift is a
blessing I've been dreaming of this
moment sday didn't open the
door
stop